ce v6
il
davies récente
quand je fais j'ai l'impression d'être
un roi un chevalier le trou
voire le seul homme sur la plaine
comme je perds
j'ai l'impression que kratos
l'arrivée au delta
prisonniers colons et
je t'aime
le geste
athènes
t
ah l'amour
avec toi
quand je fais
il est minuit
n'importe où
je t'aime
je ne sais plus si je
en tirant
mais noël
oh
je t'aime
reste le même
ah l'amour
avec toi
pour
comme je t'aime chez les +
et toi
et le ciel que je te toi le ciel
quand je t'aime
je l'avais m
et ce plaisir
on ne fait pas
le feu
comment
je t'aime
geste main
att
ah l'amour
avec toi
quand je perds
mais sion
c'est trop
c'est pas les dons
là quand je t'aime
je le
peta
comme là
missonnier
il a moins joué
à tous n'importe où mais
attentes
les bijoux sont mieux jouer le monde
applaudit ses copains